she really was in essence the first
mainstream woman interviewing heads of
state and states and popes and going
everywhere and doing absolutely
everything and getting it to the place
that it became normalized and we should
give credit to the people that do that
here's a little compilation of some of
some of Barbara's work over the years
this is just a random collection that we
put together and you know She
interviewed everybody it was celebrities
and reality TV people to literally the
pope and the president here's just a
little bite famous you don't really act
you don't sing you don't dance you don't
have any
forgive me any Talent Nikki recently
released a song it's called hell yeah
it's about American Idol and she says
I'm quick to check a [ __ ] if she is out
of line
are you the [ __ ]
she's singing about
don't know
don't know what she's saying I didn't
know she sang I thought she wrapped or
whatever I'm sitting opposite you
but you are a little overweight more
than a little yeah yeah
why
well if I could figure that out I'd fix
it do you try to diet oh Barbara I've
had I've had more diets and lost and
gained back more weight in my lifetime
than I care to count there are people
who say that you couldn't be president
because you're so heavy what do you say
to them no it's ridiculous
I don't care folks okay you want that
same guy Elizabeth calm down I can't
everybody has strong opinions and there
are many other arguments that other
people could give you I think the most
important thing which is what we see
today is we've got to be able to have
these discussions and listen to other
people's opinions and not those how
crazy that you don't listen I heard
everything you said I just am emphatic I
barely started well and it's not just my
opinion so look we could have picked a
zillion questions whether she was
interviewing Bill Clinton or Barack
Obama or literally the pope or whoever
we picked a couple that were a little
more in the culture thing but like to
say to the Kardashians to literally sit
down with the Kardashians and be like
you have no Talent like she did that to
say to sit down with Chris Christie
you're fat to do that like she really
was putting herself out there and trying
to have difficult conversations like the
Christie one is interesting because it's
like everyone kind of knows it like he
was never going to be president but and
it had something to do with his weight
right and she called him out on that
like that just is uh to the Kardashians
you've become this cultural Force you do
nothing that's interesting but really at
the end there is the one that that it
really is all about where she says
everyone has their own opinions and in
essence we have to be able to talk about
these things at the very table of the
show that she created she created The
View can you give me the year on The
View what what year did The View come
out about 25 years ago I think or so uh
and when she created it the whole idea
of the view as I said earlier was to
create this this place for women in this
case of all different walks of life to
come together and do it respectfully it
came out in 1997 25 years that's uh
that's pretty good
about 26 years ago
um but she did that and she tried to
maintain some level of let's let's have
these conversations to the best of our
ability it's the most American thing you
can do